what are three words you will use to
describe guess who
buffy okay
right i think because on this album
we show our two personalities
in the morning we get very sick
and very quiet and concealing our
emotions
so in the night we get cece and foxy
[Music]
itsy congratulations on the new album i
want to know which song on the new album
are you guys most excited
not only for fans to hear but to
eventually perform live
which song actually for me
in the morning
[Music]
in the morning performance is really
nice
and cool and chic and amazing
yeah and the new thing we try to
new concept you guys made your debut in
2019 so i'm curious
how has your style and also your sound
changed in the last two years
yeah we usually did very energetic and
confident song and color
style but this year i think guess who is
a little
more deep and dark
yeah we love to try new things
i love it so your sound is changing how
about your bond you know
what would you how would you guys
describe your bond since you made your
debut
a couple years ago has it changed at all
i would say
that uh we're like a family now
we're more like a family and we're more
like sisters now
we were actually uh pretty uh very
close together uh even before debut
because we actually
uh known each other since
um when we were really young because
we've all trained
for quite a while but i think
um like actually debuting and like going
through
like the tough times and like other
stuffs together and like crying together
like laughing together and other stuff
as a team um makes like the bond more
like harder and yeah close
yeah and also live together yeah
yeah that's very important thing
to know each other right do you guys
love living together
but very very great and cool and
really happy experience it's fun yeah
most
time right well tell me this what has
been the biggest lesson that you've
learned about being in a group together
for me i as you
can know if we get into one team
we have to be with each other whenever
and wherever
so even if you don't want to be with
someone
you have to be with someone then you
should match something with each other
and i think it get um it
makes me a big lesson for my life
so i think i learned so many things
while doing the
team in this three years
has there been any um unexpected
friendships that you guys have formed
with maybe other people in the industry
so shy person and
i don't have many friends
it is my best friend yeah
those are new friends to have yeah yeah
right okay so obviously you guys have
this new record together but are there
any plans to do any individual songs
or personal projects in the future i
think in the future
it could but from
like in right now we don't really have a
is exactly the plan for it
we because we think we have so many
things left to show as a team that's
right so
we want to show it as much as we can
then
the plan will begin i think yeah right
but right now you're enjoying doing all
these songs together yeah
right you know your fans want to know if
you're going to
travel around the world to come visit
them are there plans to go on tour
oh definitely when this whole um
case and everything gets better
definitely yeah
because because um we
we went on a showcase tour before and it
was amazing
and we really missed them and
we i don't know if we were going to but
uh we were plant planning
we were hoping to right
go on a tour um like later on
but since like um right now uh
everything's not like in a good place so
yeah
it's um it's uh good to stay safe for
everyone
but once everything gets um safe
uh we're definitely gonna go visit you
guys yeah
and yeah obviously it's been a really
tough year for a lot of people
especially within the aapi community um
what message you guys have to
the mid-seas and your fans out there who
are having a hard time right now
hi mitzi thank you for supporting
us even in this hard time we hope
it can be um energy
of your life see you soon and please
stay
safe we love you
[Music]
always